المترجم: Ghada Khalil
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
أنا سعيدةٌ جدًا لأننا في العيد،
ولأنني أتحدَّث عن حياتي وقصتي معكُم،
وأتمنى ألا يكون كلامي به الكثير من الأسى
بقدر ما يكون به من الإيجابية.
بدأَت قصتي منذُ أكتر من 25 عامًا بقليل.
لا داعي للحسابات، فعُمري هو 40 عامًأ.
وأنا متزوجةٌ وأُم لابنتين جميلتين
موجودتين هنا،
ومهندسة مدنية سابقاً،
وأنا حاليًا مُدربة تراياثلون،
وأُدير أكاديمية الأميدا الموجودة
في الشرق الأوسط.
كانت الحياة بسيطة جدًا،
حياة شِبه بدائية في مدينة الغردقة،
حيث وُلدتُ وعشتُ بها.
وكنت متفوقةً في كل شيء،
وكنت أُحب القيام بكل شيء بشكلٍ صحيح.
وذلك لأن أبي الرائع، رحِمَه الله،
كان يمدح كل ما أقوم به مهما كان صغيرًا
وكان يراه رائعًا.
ولذلك كنتُ أسعى دائمًا لأُثبت له
أنني جديرةٌ بالمسئولية وبثِقَته بي.
كانت الحياة بسيطة، وكنتُ أمارس
كل أنواع الرياضة،
وكان حلم حياتي هو أن أصبح مهندسة،
وكنتُ متفوقة جدًا.
ذاكرتُ كتيرًا، وتخطيت عدة سنواتٍ
في الدراسة.
والتحقتُ بكُلية الهندسة وكنت أبلُغ حينها
15 عامًا تقريبًا
وعلى وشك بلوغ عامي الـ16.
وكان كل شيء على ما يُرام
ولا توجد أي مشاكل.
وأثناء عبوري للشارع في يومٍ ما،
بعد أن هبطت من سيارة أجرة
اصطدمَت سيارتان،
وكادت إحداهما أن تدهسني وأنا على الرصيف.
رأيتُ الحادث كاملًا،
ولم أشعر بما حدث إطلاقًا،
ولكنّي رأيته كاملًا.
رأيتُ نفسي طائرةً في الهواء
ثم سقطتُ فوق سيارةٍ،
وذراعي الأيمن يصطدم بالعجلات
بينما كانت ساقي في اتجاهٍ آخر.
وبالطبع كان ذلك منذ أكثر من 25 عامًا،
أي أنه لم يكُن هناك أي هواتف لتصوير الحادث
ونشر الخبر لكي يعرف الناس أين أنت
وماذا حدث.
مرَّت 48 ساعة وأهلي لا يعلمون أين أنا.
ثم أتي أبي، رحِمَه الله، وأمي واستطاعوا
الوصول إليَّ،
ووجدتُ نفسي جالسةً على كرسي مُتحرك،
وكان كل طبيبٍ أقابله، مع احترامي للأطباء،
كنت أقابلهم ولدَي أملٌ كبير،
ولكنّهم كانوا يُشعرونني بيأسٍ ومأساة أكبر.
وكان حديثٍهم على شاكلة "اشكري الله أن أهلك
كان في مقدورهم شراء كرسي متحرك لكِ.
واشكري الله لأنك لم تفقدي يديك."
كانت تلك هي نوعية الردود التي أتلقاها
من كل طبيب.
وبعقلية طفلة ذات 16 عامًا فقط،
كانت تلك مأساة كبيرة للغاية.
وكنتُ أسأل أبي دائمًا:
"ماذا بعد؟"
وكان رده هو: "تذكَّري معنى اسمك.
تذكَّري معنى اسمك."
بقَيتُ شهرين أو ثلاثة في نضالٍ مع الأطباء،
وأنا أحاول اجتياز اختباراتي الجامعية،
ولكني رسبتُ في كل الاختبارات
لأن يدي اليُمنى لم تكُن تتحرك.
وكنتُ أحاول الكتابة بيدي اليُسرى، ولصعوبة
الأمر كنت أنهي ثُلث الاختبار فقط
وينتهي الوقت، فأرسُب في المواد.
بعد مرور شهرين، كان عليَّ أن أُجري
سلسلة عمليات لا حَصر لها.
وكان والدي قد سافر وتركني،
ولم يسأل عني لمدة أسبوع، فأصابني القلق.
حدَث ذلك في يوم 6 يناير 1998،
لن أنسى هذا التاريخ لأنه كان في شهر رمضان.
عُدتُ إلى الغردقة وكنت قد بدأتُ أرفض
استخدام الكرسي واستعنتُ بعكازتين بدلًا منه
لأنني كُنتُ أؤمن دائمًا أنه لا يُمكن
لطبيبٍ أو أي شخصٍ آخَر
إخباري بما هو مُقدّّر لي.
لذلك سوف أبذل قصارى جهدي،
والله وحده أعلَم بما هو مُقدّّر لي.
سافرتُ إلى الغردقة،
وفوجئتُ بأن والدي قد تُوُفي.
لم يستطع أحد أن يخبرني بذلك،
لعلمِهم بأن صدمتي ستكون كبيرة،
ولأنني لدي ما يكفيني من المتاعب،
ولن أتحمل إبلاغهم لي بخبر وفاة والدي.
مرَّت ثلاثة أيامٍ وأنا في صدمةٍ رهيبة،
وشعرت أنني أخسر كل شيء.
فقد خسرت جسدي وخسرت أبي كذلك.
ولكنني كنتُ أتذكر ما كان يقوله لي دائمًا:
"تذكَّري معنى اسمِك."
بعد مرور ثلاثة أيامٍ، كنتُ أعتقد
أن تلك هي أكبر أزمة مررتُ بها.
وكما أقول دائمًا لبناتي، عندما تحدُث
لنا مشكلةٌ ما، نتخيل أنها أزمةٌ كبيرة،
ولكننا لا نعلم ما هو آتٍ،
فربما يكون ما هو قادم أسوأ بكثير.
لذلك علينا أن نفعل ما بوسعنا بقدر الإمكان.
وبعد ثلاثة أيامٍ، اكتشفنا أننا خسرنا
كل أموالنا بعد وفاة والدي
بسبب مشكلةٍ قد حدَثَت بعد وفاته
بخصوص شراكةٍ في عمَله.
وأنه كان علينا أن نبيع كل ما نملكه،
حتى ملابسنا.
وبالطبع انهار كل فرد في العائلة
والمنزل بشكلٍ ما.
منهم من تجنَّبنا ورحَل،
ومنهم مَن أخبرنا أن مشاكلنا لا تخُصه.
ومَن انهار كُليّا وقال بأن الموت
أكرم له من ذلك.
أما أنا فقد حزمتُ حقيبتي وأخذتُ العُكازتين
وسافرتُ إلى القاهرة،
وقررت أنني سأُكمل ما بدأته،
وأنني سأكون خيرُ خلفٍ لخير سلفٍ.
فوالدي قد مات ولكنني ما زلتُ موجودة،
وسأُكمل ما بدأه.
تركتُ المنزل الذي كُنتُ مقيمة به
في القاهرة،
وأخذتُ حقيبتي وحاسوبي والعُكازتين
وجلستُ على الرصيف في الشارع.
وسألني صديقٌ لنا إلى أين سأذهب،
فأخبرته أنه ليس لدي أدنى فكرة عن ذلك،
وبالفعل لم أكن أعلم إلى أين أنا ذاهبة.
فأعطاني مفتاحًا لبيتٍ قديم،
وأخبرني أنه منزلٌ مهجور في حي السيدة زينب
يمكنني الإقامة به حتى أجد أيًّا من أقربائي
أو إلى أن أُرتب أموري.
أقمتُ في ذلك المنزل، ولم يكُن معي سوى
عشرة جنيهات.
أذكرها جيدًا، لأن المنزل
كان مهجورًا وقذرًا
ومليئًا بالحشرات، فقررت أنني سأشتري
بكل ما معي أدواتٍ لتنظيف المنزل.
ثم أفرغتُ ما بحقيبتي، وكان هذا هو المكان
الذي أقمتُ فيه لمدة أسابيع.
وكان هذا هو طعامي لمدة أسبوعين
ونصف تقريبًا؛
شاي بدون سكر وبُقسُماط،
ولم يكُن لدي طعامٌ آخر.
وبدأتُ أمشي بالعُكازتين كل يومٍ
إلى جامعة القاهرة
لمدة ساعتين إلا رُبع،
وأمشي في طريق العودة مُجدَّدًا
لمدة ساعتين إلا رُبع.
ولم يكُن لدي أي مالٍ لشراء مُسكِّن لآلامي.
دائمًا ما أقول لبناتي ولأي شخصٍ أعرفه،
هل ترون اللافتات الكبيرة التي تكون
مُعلَّقة على أبواب المنازل أحيانًا
ومكتوبًا عليها: "احذر من الكلاب"؟
احذروا أيضًا من الأصدقاء السيئين.
فعندما ذهبتُ إلى أعز صديقاتي
قُلت لها أن كرامتي تمنعني من طلب المال
من أي شخصٍ، ولكنني أرغب في العمل.
فاسألي والدك،لأنه كان يمتلك سلسلة
صيدليات كبيرة،
إذا كان بإمكانه توفير أي عملٍ لي لديه حتى
وإن كان أجري خمسة جنيهات فقط في اليوم.
يُمكنني تحريك يدي اليُسرى وأستطيع مساعدته
في تنظيف الصيدلية،
أو أقوم بأي شيء.
وكان ردها أنها ستجد لي حلًّا خلال يومين.
بعد مرور يومين، أعطتَني قُرصًا صغيرًا،
وأخبرتني أن حياتي بائسة وتعيسة
وأن القادم سيكون اسوأ،
فمن الأفضل لي أن أنهيها.
كان هذا هو حَل أعز صديقةٍ لي،
وكان ذلك اليوم هو آخر علاقتي بها
لأني قررت أنني لن أقوم بذلك،
ولن أدع أي شخصٍ يتحكم في حياتي أو مصيري
لأن الله موجود دائمًا وكذلك إرادتي.
وقررت أنني الآن بداخل نفَق،
وأنا واقفةٌ في بدايته بينما أرى في آخره
حلمًا لي، وكان ذلك الحلم هو والدي
الذي كان يتمنى أن يراني دومًا
في أحسن حال.
ذهبتُ للعمل عند أحد أساتذتي في الجامعة،
وأخبرتُه أنه يُمكنني القيام بأي شيء.
لأن طعامي كان قد بدأ ينفذ،
فكان علي أن أجد عملًا،
لم يكُن لدي حلٌّ آخر.
كنتُ أمشي من الجامعة إلى مكتبِه
لمدة 45 دقيقة،
بعد إنهاء مُحاضراتي في الجامعة بالطبع.
كنتُ أنظف المكتب بيدي اليُسرى،
وأُرتب له أوراقه وأقوم بكل شيء.
هكذا بدأتُ، إلى أن أصبحتُ
ذراعه الأيمن تقريبًا
في ذلك المكتب.
ثم أُجريت إحدى العمليات لذراعي
لأنني كنتُ على وشك أن أفقده،
وبدأت أفقد إحساسي به.
والذي أجراها لي كان طبيبًا شابًا،
ولم أكُن متأكدة من فُرص نجاح العملية
لأنني لم أكُن أملك مالًا كافيًا لإجراء
عمليةٍ كبيرة.
وسالته: "هل تعتقد أنه سيكون بإمكاني
تحريك ذراعي مُجدَّدًا؟
وأتمكن من تمشيط شعري؟"
فأخبرني أنني لدي ما أحتاجه بداخلي؛
الإرادة في عقلي والإيمان في قلبي.
ولو كُنتُ أريد تحريكه فعلًأ،
فسوف يوفقني الله لذلك.
تم إجراء العملية،
وكافحتُ كثيرًا، وتعبتُ كثيرًا،
وكنتُ آخذ المحاضرات يوميًا من أصدقائي.
ومَن كان منكُم طالبًا في كلية الهندسة
يعلَم بالطبع أنه بعد الحصول على المحاضرات،
يتم تصوير تلك الأوراق لدراستها لاحقًا.
ولأنني لم أملك مالًا كافيًا،
كُنتُ آخذ الأوراق يوميًا من أحد زملائي
وأخرج من الباب الخلفي،
ثم أعود إلى المنزل وأدَّعي أنني نسيت
أن أعيدها إليه.
بينما أنا في الحقيقة لا أملك ثمن
تصوير الأوراق.
فكنتُ أعود إلى المنزل وأستمر في كتابتها
بيدي اليُسرى طوال الليل حتى أدرسها لاحقًا.
كافحتُ وتعبتُ كثيرًا طول السنين،
وفي طريق عودتي كل يومٍ من الجامعة،
كان يوجد مكانٌ عند سور جامعة القاهرة
تُباع فيه الصُحُف الصفراء،
إذا كُنتم تعرفونها.
كنتُ أذهب إلى هناك، وكان هناك بائعٌ اسمه
عم مجدي كنتُ قد تعرفتُ عليه،
فكنتُ أحيانًا أشاركه ببعضٍ من طعامي
قبل أن ينفذ،
وكان يُعطيني إحدى تلك الصحُف.
وكُنتُ آخذها لكن ليس لأجل قراءة ما بها
من فضائح،
بل لأنه كان يوجد بها قسم خاص بالرياضة.
كان هذا بمثابة وسيلة المُساعدة لي.
وكنتُ أحاول تمرين أي عضلةٍ
حتى وإن كانت صغيرة في جسدي.
وكُنتُ أعلم أن أجزاءً كثيرة من جسدي
قد ضعفت ولكن عضلاتي ما زالت موجودة.
فقررتُ أنني سأعمل على تقويتها،
وأن الرياضة هي وسيلة المُساعدة التي يمكنها
مساعدة عقلي ونفسيتي وجسدي كي أكمل رحلتي.
استمررت على نفس الحال
حتى آخر سنةٍ لي في الكُلية،
إلى أن تزوجتُ ذلك الرجل الرائع
الذي قرر أن يُساندني.
وعندما عرَض عليَّ الزواج، سألته عن سبب
رغبته في الارتباط بي وأنا نصف جسدي مُصاب،
والله وحده أعلَم بما يخبئه لي المستقبل،
ولا أعلَم ما قد يحدُث لعائلتي لاحقًا.
قررنا أن نُكافح ونجتهد معًا،
وتركتُ الهندسة، وعملتُ بالتدريس،
وعملت في العديد من المِهَن الأخرى.
وكنتُ أعمل دائمًا وأحاول أن أدعم وأُقوِّي
جسدي بشكلٍ ما.
إلى أن اتخذتُ قراري بأن أبدأ
في مُمارسة الجَري،
وكان أول رد لزوجي هو "يُسرا، لقد بدأتِ
للتو في استعادة قدرتك على المشي بشكل أفضل"
فقُلت له: "لا، أريد أن أجري أيضًا."
ابتعدتُ عن الهندسة وركزتُ على دراسة
أي شيء له علاقة بالرياضة.
بدأت أُمارس الجَري وكان الناس يسخرون مني
لأن وزني كان أكبر مما هو عليه حاليًا
بحوالي 20 كيلو جرام تقريبًا.
كُنَّا انتقلنا للإقامة خارج مصر،
وانضممتُ إلى فريقٍ كان أغلبه من الإسبان.
وفي أول يومٍ ذهبتُ للتدريب،
كان الُمدرب يعمل على تدريب أشخاصٍ
مُحترفين للغاية،
ودخلتُ وكُلّي حماس وطاقة وأمل أن يشعر بي
ذلك المُدرب ويُساعدني.
ولكنه لم يُساعدني، بل بالعكس،
خرجتُ من التدريب وأنا أبكي
لأنه جعلني أشعر وكأني حشرةٌ صغيرة وتافهة.
وسألني ما الذي أتي بي هنا
بين أولئك الأبطال في حين أنني بلا أي قيمة.
كنتُ أعود للمنزل وأبكي بعد كل تدريب،
وكل شخصٍ يعرفني يقوم بسؤالي عن سبب
استمراري رغم كل ذلك،
فكنتُ أرد عليهم بأنني سأستمر حتى أثبت لهم
أنني أستطيع القيام بذلك وأكثر.
وبعد مرور سنة وشهرين، كنتُ قد أصبحتُ أقوى
لاعب في ذلك الفريق.
وفي كل سباقٍ نُشارك به،
كانت توجد عدَّاءةٌ صِربية مشهورة
في ذلك الفريق،
اسمها ريناتا هوبوفا،
كُنتُ أنا من يُنهي كل سباقٍ معها.
وكنتُ أفتخر بذلك بشدة.
وفي أول سباقٍ لنا في رياضة التراياثلون،
أو السباق الثلاثي التي بدأت تجذب انتباهي،
دخلتُ أحد السباقات وفُزنا بالمركز الأول.
وتلك الصورة من أحد السباقات التي فشلت فيها
ولكنني قمتُ بما عليّ.
وبالمناسبة، هاتان هما ابنتاي الرائعتين.
في ذلك السباق فُزنا بالمركز الأول،
وأثناء استلامنا للجائزة، لم أكُن سعيدة.
وقلتُ لهم "لقد جَريتُ فقط.
وأود أن أتعلم السباحة وركوب
الدراجات أيضًا."
وبالطبع كانت فكرة تحريكي لذراعي
ليست سهلة على الإطلاق،
فبدأتُ من الصفر.
وبدأتُ أتدرب وأجتهد بشدة،
وكنتُ أذهب إلى التدريب في السادسة صباحًا
في طقسٍ ومياهٍ شديدي البرودة.
وكان ذلك هو المكان الوحيد المُتاح
لدي لأتدرب فيه.
وكان هذا يوم أن فُزنا بالمركز الأول.
كنتُ أضحك في الصورة ولكنني قررتُ بعدها
أن أُكمل الطريق وحدي.
بعد وصولي لذروة نجاحي،
وفي تلك الصورة كان قد تم استضافتي
في جمعية النساء الأمريكيات في الكويت،
وكنتُ عُضوة شرف بها،
لأنهم رأوا أنني إنسانة مُجتهدة ومُكافحة.
بدأتُ أُصاب بجلطاتٍ في ساقي،
وأجريتُ عمليةً تلو الأخرى، وتدهورَت حالتي
مرة أخرى.
وفي ذلك الوقت، قررتُ أنني سأعمل في مجال
الرياضة وسأقوم بدراسته عبر الإنترنت
وسأحصل على شهاداتٍ تؤهلني للتعمُّق فيه،
لأنني كنتُ أدرك كَم المعاناة،
وما يشعر به أي شخصٍ عندما يسعى
للتدريب فيقوم الآخرون بالاستخفاف
أو الاستهانة به بسبب وزنه الزائد.
أو عندما تطلب من أحدٍ أن يُشاركك في الجري،
ويرفض مُتعللًا بألم رُكبتيه.
ورَدي على ذلك هو أن يستمع إلى قصتي،
ثم يُقرر بعدها ما إذا كان
يستطيع أن يجري أم لا.
تعبتُ كثيرًا جدًا على مدى السنين،
وأُزيلَت أجزاءٌ كثيرة من رجلي اليُمنى،
لدرجة أنني كنت أشعر بالإحراج عند ارتدائي
الرداء ومُشاركتي معهم في أي سباقٍ
لأنني كنتُ أخشى أن يراها الناس
بهذه الحالة.
والآن أقوم بذلك وأنا فخورةٌ بنفسي،
لأن كل ما حدث لي هو ما جعلني
قادرة على الوقوف والتحدّث إليكم الآن.
شاركتُ في سباقاتٍ في الكثير من دول العالم.
وشاركتُ في واحدٍ من أصعب السباقات
وهو سباق الرجُل الحديدي،
الذي اشتهر حاليًا في مصر
أو في العالم كله، ويُعتبر من أكبر السباقات
في الوقت الحالي.
بدأتُ أعمل كمُدربة، وبدأنا نعمل
في الأكاديمية العظيمة،
أكاديمية الأميدا.
وأنا فخورةٌ جدا أنني أتدرب بها
وأُدرّب آخرين أيضًا.
هذا هو أحد السباقات التي كانت في ماليزيا،
وفيه يقومون بنشر صور أول 40 أو 50 مُتسابق
في الصفحات الأولى من الصُحُف
لأنه أكبر سباق هناك.
لم أتخيل أبدًا أنني قد أتمكن من المُشاركة
في ذلك السباق
ولكنني وجدتُ اسمي في تلك الصفحة
في يوم السباق.
وهذه هي عائلتي الجميلة.
ووالدي، رحِمَه الله،
الذي علَّمَني معني اسمي.
كان يقول لي: "اسمك هو يُسرا."
وعندما كنتُ طفلة صغيرة لم أكُن أفهم معناه.
ولكنني سمعتُ آيةً في القُرآن تقول:
"إنّ معِ العُسر يُسرا".
أي أنه يوجد يُسرٌ بعد كُل عُسر،
وهو لا يأتي من الفراغ،
أنت من تُقرر الحصول على ذلك اليُسر،
وتعمل من أجل ذلك،
وأنت الذي بإمكانك الوصول إليه.
كُل عامٍ وأنتُم بخير،
وأتمنى ألا أكون قد أثقلتُ عليكُم.
(تصفيق)